and starting now from Nashville more
live coverage of the Southern Festival
of Books this is National Book Award
finalist our Lee Russell Hoke shield
morning
you
I've got a couple of housekeeping
announcements on what I made
session the author will be at the
signing colonnade and available to to
talk books are also available at the
main sales table and the festival itself
is free but if you would like to make a
donation you can go to humanities
Tennessee org and it would be greatly
appreciated so now on to the main event
our author today is our Lee Russell hook
shield and her book is stranger in their
own land so I want to read a bio I've
made a mistake before of not reading the
bio and so I'm gonna actually read it
instead of trying to memorize it our Lee
is the author of nine books among them
stranger in their own land anger in the
morning on their own right a finalist
for the National Book Award this year by
the way just announced congratulations
other books include second shift working
parents and the Revolution at home the
time bind when home becomes work and
work becomes home and a managed heart
the commercialization of the of the
intimate life she's been awarded the
Ulysses medal from University College
Dublin Ireland as well as the Guggenheim
Mellon Fulbright fellowship four of her
books have been named a National New
York Times notable non-fiction book of
the year and her work appears in 16
languages
she's a sociology professor emeritus at
UC Berkeley she lives in Berkeley
California with her husband Adam welcome
arleigh thank you thank you thank you
very much
that's great to be here what I thought
we could do is I'll spend a little bit
of time taking you on a journey with me
that I've just come home from and then
we can open it out to questions and
comments five years ago
I sense like so many of us did a split
between left and right that was getting
more extreme each side was hardening and
that we lived in kind of enclaves so
that I would talk to my husband and best
friend we've chat her way we agree and
then I would open the newspaper and say
oh my God look there's there two treats
here there's this I'm not living in the
whole world or I look at television and
feel the same and I knew that actually
other Americans were in the same
situation that we live in media enclaves
in technological enclaves and in
Geographic enclaves Berkeley California
teaching sociology I was in a super
Enclave so I thought I want to get out
of my Enclave take my political and
moral alarm system off and permit myself
to get very curious about the lives of
people who lived in an enclave as far
away and as distant from my own as I
could where would that be the split
between this mic oh okay wrong like the
split between left and right it's not
because the left has gotten more left
but because the right has gotten more
right and more people are on the right
so I thought that has mainly that change
has happened mainly in the south so good
I wanted to go to the
but we're in the south
I saw in 2012 that while half of whites
voted for Obama in California and about
1/3 did in the south as a whole region
14% did in Louisiana so I thought great
I want to go to Louisiana
and I wanna I want to talk to whites who
else older whites maybe especially
religious older whites in Louisiana so
our voyage starts there with a question
I went with this red state paradox in
mind how is it true that in the United
States the most red states are also the
poorer States once with a worse
education with worse health and lower
life expectancies those states receive
more funds from the federal government
in aid than they give in tax dollars and
yet are the most suspicious and
resistant to the idea of a federal
government well that's really
interesting what what goes on with that
and Louisiana is a super red state
paradox because in 2014 it was the
poorest state 44% of its state budget
came from the federal government and it
was very largely very largely a tea
party and drunk so it was perfect I was
there at the at an exaggerated version
of the red state paradox and then I made
one more move it's not okay a lot of
people who are doing well have worked
hard
and have succeeded economically wouldn't
themselves want Medicaid or food stamps
and I could understand perhaps their
opposition to that but how about the
environment I wake up and look and it
was kind of foggy you know and there
were certain smell around the place and
sometimes my eyes would sting if I was
in Westlake this was a petrochemical
Center very proud to say it was the
buckle of America's energy belt more
petrochemical companies being lured in
with an incentive money in order to use
the cheap natural gas produced by
fracking so but there was something in
the air and people were drinking bottled
waters I bet Wayman let's look at the
environment here it's staring me in the
face I didn't go there with that in mind
but it was unavoidable
I discovered that Calcasieu Parish which
is in the parish around Lake Charles in
the southwest of Louisiana which is a
center of this petrochemical industry
was among the 2% most polluted in the
country and yet there was no discussion
of the need to regulate the polluters
and in fact people were voting for
people who said nothing about pollution
so there I was right almost the keyhole
of the red-state paradox and I want to
tell you take you on a journey with me
to meet some of the most extraordinary
interesting complex lovely caring people
who were at the center of this paradox
meet Harold and Annette Arena
I am seated on a soft living-room couch
in the home of Harold a gentle Cajun
pipefitter who was carefully holding
before me from his adjacent chair a
large photo album he draws his hand back
and forth over the plastic covers on the
black and white photos he turns the
pages slowly searching for one-77 and a
former deacon in the lighthouse
Tabernacle Pentecostal Church he's
dressed in a plaid shirt and jeans he
speaks in a slow baritone his eyes on
the page often concluding a line of
thought with a light chuckle as if to
say it's alright he points there it is
his mother father himself and nine
siblings standing in two rows squinting
into the Sun on the banks of Bayou den
it is 1950 Harold names his brothers and
sisters he tells how his mother used to
catch gar by coaxing the fish to the
side of the boat with bait patting their
sides then lifting them by the gills
into the boat but it's not just his
family he wants me to see as if
introduced ting friendly neighbors he
points behind the family to something
else standing proud in the water behind
the faces in the photograph our
commanding bald cypress trees large
triangular trunks rising from the water
once the glorious Queens of the forested
wetland of southern Louisiana and still
the official state tree green moss hangs
from outstretched lower branches tree
after tree like lace shawls in a dance
hall throw a Cajun in a swamp
Harold chuckles his eyebrows lifting for
emphasis and he can make a living but
that was before
before what that was before the
petrochemical industry came and began to
pollute public waters and to contaminate
the fish and to lead to blinded Turtles
with white eyes kind of looking out not
seeing the bugs they could eat to stay
alive and starving and before the cows
tipped over and before everyone else in
heraldry knows family got cancer and
everybody but he and him his own wife
died was a lot to take in I thought wow
I interviewed the man who actually did
the polluting Lee Sherman just saw him a
few days ago when I went back to
Louisiana which was the first thing I
did after the book came out to put on a
dinner for the people that I wrote about
and their friends the guy who did the
polluting and the victims of it because
they feel the victim at something bigger
so Harold and Annette are voting I have
voted Republican all their lives and
they're thinking about voting for Trump
they're not sure these days and they
didn't like that Trump was imitating
disabled people that really as good
religious people they were appalled at
that and the accusations very much
I took them aback but they were thinking
about it and of course Trump wants to
abolish the Environmental Protection
Agency
so we're still right there in this red
state paradox and the key whole issue of
it so we just outline some some things
that I discovered that felt to them more
important than the paradox that I from
Berkeley California
came in curious about something bigger
was there for them and I think it was
this it was really three things in the
south the federal government is the
north right okay I wouldn't give that a
lot of weight but I think it's they're
kind of in the background and I treat
that in the book then they look at the
regulator's and it's very interesting
because in Louisiana the regulator's are
part of the state government which has
been what scholars would say captured by
oil that is the state government is run
by oil men or those who owe their
campaign financing to oil and pretty
much do else bidding meanwhile so that
Governor Jindal gave 1.5 billion dollars
in incentive money to these
petrochemical and oil companies say oh
please come to Louisiana and don't go to
Texas so with that 1.5 billion dollars
the companies began to give out
donations to the Audubon Society
you know let's preserve the birds and to
third grade science classes and uniforms
for Louisiana State football team so
people love the companies they thought
the jobs but not many jobs only 16
percent of jobs in Louisiana have to do
at all with the oil companies these are
highly
automated plants and the people they
bring in are often from out of state so
to run the petrochemical company you
would want an MIT chemist and then a
Filipina pipe fitters are brought in so
there are jobs but not many but people
looking at the at the company say well
some jobs at least and and a lot of
goodie bags so but they look at the
state and they see a state that isn't
actually protecting them where people
have been hired to present the illusion
of protection without providing the
reality of it in essence you might say
the state has been given the moral dirty
work to do to seem to protect but not
really protect people and and so people
were mad at the state didn't do its job
why should I pay taxes to this
do-nothing state especially since I
haven't had a raise in two decades and
jobs are a little more shaky than they
were so that's a second reason first
it's government as an instrument of the
north then government is instrument of
oil and then they don't put it together
quite the way I just have but there's a
third thing I came to this whole project
with an interest in emotions and
feelings and I think we get to the
feelings underneath politics both right
wing politics and left wing liberal
politics by looking at what I call a
deep story
what's a deep story it's a story that
feels true you take out moral judgments
you take out facts and you have a story
that is how it feels
what is the arena's deep story or that
of the other 40 people over five years I
came to really know well sixty
interviews and all the deep story is
this imagine that you're in a line as in
a pilgrimage going to the top of a hill
where there is the American dream you
have worked very hard for this American
dream you've been patient and you're a
good person you don't begrudge anybody
but your your line isn't moving toward
that dream and then you see some people
seeming to cut ahead of you I think ah
what's that about well who are they
these line cutters well those would be
blacks on affirmative action who had now
have access to jobs formerly reserved
for whites those would be women who are
have access to jobs formerly reserved
for men that would be immigrants it
would be refugees even public sector
workers like some of these people
working in Environmental Protection in
the state agency what are they doing why
are they there so then in the deep story
you see someone Barack Hussein Obama who
seems to be whose job it is to be
impartial and supervise the line for
everyone but you see him waving to the
line cutters he's their president he is
doing for them and he's leaving me out
in fact am I kind of like a minority
group although I don't talk about
minorities I I'm sort of back there as
especially as a white man and and in
fact isn't Obama one of those line
cutters himself I heard time and again
how did he get to Harvard his mother was
a single mom they didn't have two cents
to put together and how did he get to
Columbia something's rigged um things
rigged
so he's one of them and he's not
representing me
so another thing in this in the end
somebody turns around who's ahead of the
line and looks back and says oh you're
just a southerner you're ill educated
you're ignorant and you're a redneck and
then you just feel whipped you feel
insulted you feel marginalized you feel
when I came to call kind of a an honor
squeeze all the sources of honor to
which you turn are locked down first you
want honor for working as hard as you
have and having some economic recompense
but you know the machine has ground to a
halt so you can't do that well but
you're a very good you're a true
believer you're a highly religious
person as the arenas are but you living
an increasingly secular society that
that thinks what you believe is wrong
and your family living and your you have
your values about a good family a true
woman and now the law of the land is
saying you're right your beliefs are
wrong your scene is backward so social
and then demographically you feel there
are fewer fewer people like us and they
came to feel almost like a Native
American tribe that was in fact a
stranger in its own land and when you
add to the fact the arenas feel that the
ground is not their ground the bayou
is not there by you the fish are not
there their fish the trees are not there
they were in mourning for those trees
they loved those large cypress trees and
they were gone they were stumps in the
bayou so they felt like strangers in
their own land and we can see the anger
but I don't think we can see the morning
that a lot of people are feeling
so in the end the state was an
instrument for the north it was an
instrument of oil and it was an
instrument of the line cutters they felt
in their deep story making them
strangers in their own land so I'm going
to just end with these thoughts I began
with one paradox but I ended up with
another the paradox I ended up with was
how could the Democratic Party call
itself you know the party of the working
people and to have working people
leaving it in droves like that's the
paradox for people who have a different
a deep story and are in the liberal left
a very important paradox because I
because of this my husband Adam and I
were recently in Hungary where were
giving talks in Budapest where a very
right-wing leader auradon has taken over
and as you know the there's been a loss
of the Free Press a consolidation of
power and all the statutes have been
changed in Budapest there used to be of
many different ethnicities and now
they're all heroic Hungarian figures and
actually the history of the Hungarian
role in the persecution of the Jews in
world war ii has been erased if you look
at all the statues there is no sign of
that anymore recently these have been
changed so I asked
a an observer gee what happened because
Hungary was just dying to get itself out
of the claws of the Soviet Union and was
thrilled and relieved to finally be part
of the European Union and it loved
democracy and the Free Press and how
could this happen and the man says sir
was this nobody thought it could happen
and the left was turned in on itself
divided and did not vote just end there
Thank You Orly we want to open up the
room for questions now we do have at
least 30 minutes for some questions and
we do have a microphone right over here
so because we are on TV if you could
come up to the microphone if you have a
question and it will address those
so first I wanted to thank you for
bringing some empathy to this election
cycle I've been so disheartened being
sensitive to all the tone of derision
that has really permeated especially
among the laughs how could these people
think this way and there's so much other
in which is just furthering the problem
in the first place but I think there's a
lot of misperception as of this election
as the endgame and it's not a you know
it's just an event so how do we think
beyond the election because if Trump
gets elected the left is going to feel
hurt and alienated if Hillary gets
elected it just continues this strangers
in their own land paradox how do we
continue the empathy after the election
wonderful question absolutely goes to
the core of what I've tried to do with
this book let me just tell you a story
about but I came to call the empathy
wall that we all need to scale about
actually how wonderful it is to climb it
it's not a chore it's not hard its soul
enlarging and I met a incredible gospel
singer at the Republican women of
Southwest Louisiana meeting is very well
organized and huge attendance and I was
at this luncheon table and across the
way was this wonderful gospel singer and
her husband was the minister of a very
large Pentecostal church and she said I
love Rush Limbaugh you know the
conservative radio commentator and I
thought I really like to talk to her I
have something to learn and so we did
the next day we met for sweet teas and
we talked and I said what was it what's
the appeal of fresh lemon well he hates
these feminazi 'he's a little moment
there and and what is a feminine sea
well you know
Cole tough hard sort of self-centered
personal destroying families and okay
and and she went on to environmental
wackos and all of these and then she
asked me is it hard for you to hear what
I am saying and a bell went off I
thought actually no it's not hard I'm
I'm not here to to have a debate I'm
here to learn you know I spent my my
life teaching students but now the fun
part is is learning and she said I do
that too
that's not hard for me either and then
we had that in common and then she
explained that actually she saw Rush
Limbaugh's defending her against this
hail of epithets that came she thought
from liberal land you know that she was
seen as as fat and homophobic and sexist
and racist and she she saw him as pretty
defending her from that well I learned a
ton over those sweet teas so I guess
what I'm doing is making an invitation
for us to continue this voyage over the
empathy wall later she said you're my
first Democratic friend you know you
don't agree on a lot of things but hey
you you you've established a floor of
respect and liking on which a lot more
can be said ambivalences can be admitted
complexities arrived you know you're
real people on both sides and it's
fantastic so I just think that after
this election whoever wins that people
it especially liberals and progressives
I think need to actually
reach out not be turned inward there's
something called living room
conversations that have been started
where left and right get together they
break food break bread together and I
just love to see those living room
conversations all over the country
thanks for the question
thank you yeah I would just add I'm a
nurse and I would say that it's just
incredible what happens when people feel
heard yes yeah hi early my name is
Stacey Harris I'm originally from
Minneapolis just to give you some
background here and I make people feel
comfortable if dear long ago I lived
anywhere else but I tell people that I'm
from Southern Minnesota and make them
feel more home one thing that I've
noticed today is this topic intrigued me
as well well as your your other books
and the fact that this audience is
overwhelmingly white but I will point
out that Tennessee is the home of Albert
Gore senior and junior in particular
with regard to the environment but my
question is this because we're talking
about paradoxes and so forth and one of
the things that I noticed I'm one of the
people that's in this bind of voting for
the lesser of two evils and I was
looking at the third parties and I
discovered that the Tennessee ballot has
either six or seven choices on it of
those three or four I don't even have I
can't really even get any information I
may have to google further but one of
the choices intrigued me and that was
the constitution party because not being
an evangelical I don't I don't profess
to know how evangelicals think other
than in terms of how I reacted their
thinking but but what I can't understand
is and and this is nothing new that the
people that are the evangelicals that
are voting for Trump in spite of all the
reasons that they don't want to vote for
him why they are not flocking to the
constitution party now in Tennessee the
Constitution party is not on the ballot
it will be a write-in vote and the
write-in votes don't count and I've been
a crusader for years about having your
write-in vote count
it used to be listed in the news
because I said I think that says
something and in this year in particular
I think it's going to say something and
so that's the extent of my comments I'm
interested in your answers yeah thank
you yeah of the people that I came to
know I don't know anyone that is voting
for a third-party candidate at all and
including the Constitution Party and
thought about it but they're they're not
thinking of doing it it's it's
interesting that a lot of the Tea Party
people I talked to actually have a
friendly feeling toward Bernie Sanders
they say oh uncle Bernie you know
pie-in-the-sky is not realistic you know
I don't think he's got his platform down
but you know there was a friendly
feeling and not toward Hillary but
toward Bernie so that was that told me a
lot actually out fishing had a couple of
beers and I was out fishing with a guy
super trump super Tea Party and dealing
with the contradiction which there is is
between those two this tea party wants a
really slim down government you know and
Trump it would seem mistake wanting a
hole was sort of that how do you get rid
of every undocumented worker you're
gonna need a surveillance state
it'll cost an arm and leg so I think
that's their paradox to deal with but
anyway this guy was dealing with that at
one point he said it's put his line out
he said you know let's get rid of money
out of our politics on both sides
it's just polarizing us I thought wow of
a real crossover issue there you know
you're good friends on that you think of
his enemies would completely agree with
that and he said you know they're these
politicians they're trying to pit us
against each other
so this is what the heart of quote the
opposition from from the left point of
view are saying very reasonable and
interesting things so whether they vote
for whoever they vote for I see a lot of
crossover issues that we couldn't begin
with thank you for your work this
question I think dovetails neatly from
what you were just saying I spent about
two-thirds of my relatively young life
so far in the rural South I've lived
here for about nine years
you didn't mention a lot of the
following in your discussion but I have
a theory having spent a lot of time in
the rural South that social issues
controversial social issues like
abortion same-sex marriage tend to be
the threshold tend to tip things
politically in the south toward the
right not so much the economics not so
much the government being the north I'd
like to hear your thoughts on on that
particular issue yeah I think that's
right that kind of corresponds with my
impression I going back to this honor
squeeze I kind of felt that many of
these social issues about same-sex
marriage or a right to abortion are if
if those things if the if the whole
society changes its view on those things
and a quite fundamental part of their
selves is challenged as dwarfed is
Dishonored
and I think it is very important and in
a way these issues have have gained
federal currency national currency
without the kinds of conversations that
in
act cross the empathy wall you know I
don't know as those conversations have
really happened on those issues one man
told me you know the south is changing
too but we want to change at our own
pace and they felt that things were
being shoved down their throat well
that's an interesting comment that I
think speaks to to your point yeah
there's been some interesting talk
recently about the effects of people's
on I guess geospatial experiences on
their political views so for instance
the Atlantic recently reported that
Trump has a 26% lead on people who still
live in their hometowns there's another
research showing that you know the South
is in some way
southerners strayed the least far from
home I think they said the median
southerner lives nine miles from his or
her mother spoke with you know how many
of them are still living in their
hometowns and of those who are still
living in the regional area how many of
them have have traveled what kinds of
first-hand knowledge do the people in
your book have about the world outside
their particular parish and Louisiana
that's great that's great
yeah what we do have is contrast between
locals and cause of politics and you
could say to put labels on it but the
people I came to know probably did live
nine miles from their mother and there's
a good reason they love where they are
they're committed and to their
communities and don't want you know
government messing with that community
so when they travel and they travel
elsewhere in the south or you know maybe
all of us when we travel don't actually
travel that we you know you get on a
plane if you're in Berkeley California
or
New York Los Angeles and what do you do
you go to London or Paris to go to
another city in an urban area or from
one coast to another and then what are
you really learning the people I came to
know were extremely knowledgeable about
things locally one man I went fishing
with could describe the face of ten
kinds of fish you know teeth I mean I
never thought about it before you know
or the the sound of a frog you know
these these were these were part of the
population and he knew them well and I
once tried out on I was thinking about
empathy and how empathy works and I said
to one of women choose an accountant
well do you think that actually left and
right are equally impactful
and that actually you know Liberal
Democrats are more likely to empathize
with people they don't know that could
be you know the Syrian refugees or
whatever and whereas people on the right
are more likely to empathize and be
willing to sacrifice for people they do
know for example the the Cajun Navy that
just rescued people from the floods
around Baton Rouge would be an example
of enormous amount of help and sacrifice
to those local so I said this to this
person she said what now we're we're she
was tea party she said no our church has
a foreign mission in Africa and here are
the pictures of little children in
Africa and you can see them on the cork
board and the hall of the church and I
said yes but isn't that partly too that
these mission this mission has as its
goal to teach them about Pentecostalism
you know what she said
you got me there they were wonderful
people with great sense of humor and you
can tell just by her comment the space
that that opened out when both sides
feel freer come from a proud history of
southern rednecks who and I pursued my
own education would remind me not to get
above my raisings
yeah I heard a conversation on public
radio I think Chris tippet who does a
program about spirituality interviewing
ruby sales who is a black activist who
began her work during the birmingham
years when she was teenager she said
something that was most interesting
she says that first of all she wants to
go to Appalachia and begin a movement
among the whites she has learned she
said to ask a different question not a
policy question not a political question
not a welfare question but she asks
where does it hurt oh good how does it
affect you yeah where does it wound you
and she says that's the start of a
different conversation yeah I think
she's right and she thinks that going to
Appalachia in the South a black woman
beginning a movement to simply sit down
and say where does it hurt is a way to
start a new conversation I'd like your
response or thought about that my
response is Bravo I think she's fabulous
and I think that is in fact where
exactly you could say where my book
points that it points to ruby sails
thank you for a wonderful talk my
question is how do you bring in the
facts to counter these deep stories
because at the end of the day I think
some of these deep stories are actually
hurting them how do you as an educator
see how we can overcome this and say
these are the plain facts on which you
can draw your opinions leaving politics
out of it yeah
wonderful wonderful question yeah deep
stories can hurt both those that the
deep story is about of course and the
very people who hold these deep stories
and in a way that's kind of what my book
is trying to do I feel it's kind of a
gift like here's how it looks to me I
could be wrong but I think you're
hurting from from your own positions
although I understand your suspicions
about state government I mean I that's
what I learned that captive states are
create a lot of this hurt and an account
for some of the misdirection from my
point of view of blame but yeah I think
we're these last two comments are
pointing to what hurts but you're saying
so now what how what are the policy
implications of that well I think we
could begin a a movement now and a
brooby sales kind of movement that in
fact moved gradually from the deep story
and the hurt to what to be done what
could be done about it in an open
atmosphere a lot of public square open
forums that set this tone because we
think of politics apart from tone but
tone is everything tone is a lot and if
we get the right tone then I think we
can have the right kind of
Sofer conversations about removing some
of the causes of pain in the case of
these Louisianans getting some genuine
regulation of polluting industries and
and in the case of many other issues as
you know there's now a left-right kind
of agreement that we need to reduce
prison populations that these were
nonviolent crimes people get locked up
the prisons are now privatized and
becomes in the interest of the prisoner
prison guards to kind of keep people in
because they get that it's profitable to
do so and that there's a whole logic
that takes people especially black men
away from their families so if you're a
family oriented in your in your politics
and moral beliefs that seems like a good
thing
prisons are expensive States paying for
it in the end so hey what are we doing
here
left and right can agree and I think
there are a number of issues when you
get down to the details that people
could agree on thank you I'm from North
Carolina you've heard awful lot about
what we used to consider one of the most
progressive states in the Union of late
I'm also an evangelical a retired
military person and a retired minister
and I felt compelled when the lady said
she didn't know anything about
evangelicals to tell her that every time
I hear that word on television in the
last year I cringe our job as ministers
of the gospel of Jesus Christ was not to
present ourselves and to build ourselves
up but to take a message and that
is what a true ab angelical tries to do
is not present himself but to present--
christ and the claims of Christ own own
lives and to do it in whosoever will let
him come right and I just feel I felt
compelled to say that because that is
the message of Christ whosoever will let
him come unto me and that's an a true of
Angelica and the people that stand up
and condone in my opinion saying any of
the things which are offensive to
anybody on either side is
misrepresenting Jesus Christ and when I
saw some of the college presidents and
pastors and all this talk about their
endorsement I said my friend to myself
you're not presenting Christ
it's a whosoever will message so there
are a few of us still in North Carolina
that are trying and and will continue to
try yeah and I just felt as a Tar Heel
in a evangelical and a retired minister
and retired military person to say that
well wonderful
god bless you I didn't tell you how to
vote could I tell one story my I was a
thirty year old man and I was called to
a church in a textile mill village tale
and it was close to the election and I
said to the people and this was a day
when the ministers didn't get up there
and tell their people how to vote they
told him to vote and I said if you'll
come next Sunday I'm going to tell you
how to vote the largest congregation
that I had the whole time I was pastor
of the church for 12 years came and they
were standing in pact and standing
around the wall because nobody was
telling the minister was not telling
them how to vote and I said I came out
didn't step in the pulpit stepped out in
front of the congregation and I said
first of all if you don't have a car get
a person to take it to the Pope and
secondly you stand in your line and I
just described it that's how you vote
well we have reached the end of our time
here huh thank everybody for their
questions and their stories and we're
still trying here in Tennessee too sir
so don't feel bad but we can continue
the discussion with our Lea in the
styling colonnade and just want to again
say congratulations for being chosen as
finalists for National Book Award thank
you Rangers in their own land
thank you very much charlie
[Applause]